i wanna i wanna i wanna jump to this
story real quick too we carry this on
just uh talking about
what happened in shinzo abe gun control
we're also talking about religion and
things like that which made me think of
you know a handmaid's tale and i have
this tweet i'm gonna read it because i
don't care if i get in trouble on you
know youtube or whatever so i tweeted um
the good news is that once guns are
banned the handmaidens will have no way
to fight back against fascists and will
be forced to carry babies for fat
insults wow
so i just you know i thought of this
because i'm on facebook and i'm just
like
scrolling through it and then i see
i see an individual who posted two memes
the first meme was a handmaiden and it
was like
the theocratic fascists are forcing
women to carry babies or whatever and
the next one was like we should ban all
guns i'm sick of this just ban all of
them and i'm like who do you think will
then have the guns yeah like you think
you're being ruled like you're you're if
you're in the handmaid's tale and then
you want the theocratic fascists to have
all the guns and i was like maybe this
will be like a way for you to understand
why that's a bad thing
yeah
what was the name of the country uh
it had mainstay i've never seen it
i read it or read it or anything i don't
know you don't know
nobody knows it's so stupid let me uh
hop out the window and just uh take a
guess here
italy
no no no it was like it was in north
america but they changed the name of the
country and it was like
women were forced to oh this is a
fictional place yeah yeah
lightly fictionalized okay because it
looks very catholic
the garb
well that was the idea it was very
puritan not catholic yeah like a
religion took over
and now all these people are like we're
living in the handmaid's tale quick give
the government your guns the republic of
gilead
gilead
yeah that's right because these people
have only read uh two books harry potter
and the handmaid's tale yep but as
jameis points out often they probably
didn't even read the books they watched
the adaptation
and this is it's a strongly patriarchal
white supremacist totalitarian this is
at least from wikipedia it could be
anything theonamic
theocratics here what's a theonomics i
guess like the economy is based on
religion or something
like the god god king is on the coin and
stuff
like maybe
maybe they're getting at something you
know what's like really handmaid's tale
is
the fact that like pubescent girls are
put on the pill at like age 12
or like surrogacy is so common i got it
theonomy is hypothetical form of
government ruled by christian divine law
in which non-christians are excluded
from citizenship i thought that was
theocracy that sounds healthy actually
yeah well in a theocracy you can i think
you can be a non-you cannot practice the
religion and still be assassinated but
in a theology you have to apparently
yeah or excluded hypothetical though so
maybe it's never
no one's ever existed before i like how
there's always one book they're like
it's 1984 and then a law changes no it's
the handmaid's tale harry potter because
it's 1984 again what was biden's
executive order something about
reproductive rights did you guys see
yeah oh yeah i saw something about that
what did he say again he said end of
line end of quote repeat the line that's
what he did that was the whole thing
that was the whole executive order uh
it's it's it's extremely limited let me
see if we can pull out because we didn't
have it pulled up uh there's not a whole
lot that he can do
but uh we do have the story here if it
loads we're getting we're being yeah i
had some slow energy timcast.com has
given us the business i debated a
congressional candidate a democrat
congressional candidate on the topic on
that topic roe v wade and
the decision and she actually
capitulated at the end
really yeah like what was what was your
what was your stance like what were we
saying i just said let's can we go by
like the actual scotus decision in the
verbiage in the held section right i
think it's dobbs versus jackson or
whatever and i was like can we just read
what it says and and judge that decision
and say is this decision fair yeah and
she had to capitulate it was after yeah
i mean like after you you know tell me
your his hour history or whatever of all
the bad things white people have done to
black people right but here's the funny
thing about the debate she said um she
would mandate
did you have yeah she said she wouldn't
mandate her fascists bro but she came on
the podcast saying that she was all for
body autonomy with the whole roe v wade
situation and i'm just like how do you
even so i said to her i said they're not
you just sat here and told me every
reason why we can't trust white folk and
then all of a sudden when it comes to
this all of a sudden it's like we gotta
listen to them and i'm just like it's
not about women's healthcare it's about
control
it's a it's they
you got really it is it is about control
because if you look at if we if if roe v
wade was never overturned that means
that scotus can weigh in on birth rights
let me eliminate or keep a b i just got
to say it yo um
leftists you're an occult and i'll tell
you why um abortion is defined by the
cdc as the the uh terminating a
pregnancy in a way that that does not
result in a live birth
that would mean that ectopic pregnancies
these are not abortions planned
parenthood outright says the uh i forgot
the name do you you know the name of the
operation for uh
ectopic pregnancy is it was an l
it's not an abortion it's a surgical
procedure they have to do yeah uh there
was a story there's there's a bunch of
stories they're talking about where it's
like
uh one woman was like i had a dead baby
you know in my womb and they wouldn't
take it out it's like that's not an
abortion
that's a miscarriage and there's a name
stopping me sorry
planned parenthood even even talks about
this abortion is when you end the
pregnancy and and there's no live birth
so the baby is
so that's the abusive language well the
problem is these people don't understand
that so they're like i see these memes
and they go it's not about pro-life it's
about controlling women and it's like
the supreme court did not ban abortion
yeah you're talking about texas yeah
take it up with texas right yeah but but
when the supreme court goes we do not
have the authority over the states and
they cry about it they're fascists
they're the they're the authoritarians
who want to control you and have no
logic behind them around the problem is
the supreme court's acknowledging they
don't have the the right to decide for
people right but why would they give
that power to the governors like a
governor can decide for its entire state
that's because that's how the gov
constitution works yeah 10th amendment
says
the states make their own rules
basically what they're what the the the
held section says is we are uh
taking the authority and overturning it
or it says returning it
so if you're saying returning authority
that means they held authority but if
they return it to the states not today
and the people yeah but not to the
governor solely like that because
the legislature
but the governor is 11 17 how many the
legislature how many people are in a
state legislation they're all different
some have some have hundreds it depends
on how they draw up their every state
has their own constitution some some
states are commonwealth our commonwealth
systems some states are not some have a
general i think nebraska i think is a
general assembly and then some have
representatives and senators it's all
different yeah but basically what scotus
is saying is
the term abortion does not exist
anywhere in this document right because
the people that created this country
weren't heathens like you anyway
but this term isn't in here and so
because it's in
it doesn't exist in here we don't have
any jurisdiction over it what we do have
jurisdiction over however is the fourth
amendment so if you want to claim that
your privacy was violated by having this
operation done you can come back here
and say yo they violated my privacy want
to get okay cool you can't do that
states and that's a plausible argument
but you can't say i got the right to an
abortion because there's nowhere in the
constitution the word abortion you can
just press control f on it and the word
just doesn't pop up and that's all the
scottish document is saying and what i
think it's it's very deleterious
for for the left especially like i'm not
gonna say it's celebrities because
celebrities don't know no better
but for the people that know better to
manipulate women and make them believe
that this decision banned abortion
i thought was really evil like there's
women out here that are gonna have
real emotional reactions to this right
women are going to be crying
what if you break down crying in the
middle you know driving home you crash
like you're putting people's lives at
risk instead of saying hey can we teach
you how to read a scotus document a
scotus decision and then you can
interpret this however you see you see
you see what happens with brett
kavanaugh at uh was it morton's
steakhouse
they show up he has to exit out the back
and then people started calling in fake
reservations to just jam up and hurt the
business see
you know these are crazy days indeed but
they are fascists like you said right
and people throw that work word around a
lot
yes so so
the reality is they're they're
they're more communist
and i don't mean that in the sense of
ideological communism i mean in the
sense of the like literal communism
fascists tend to be ultra traditionalist
authoritarian yeah that was a general
idea with what we saw in europe and then
you had the communists both of them had
a salute both of them would raise their
right arm the nazis would do the open
hand roman salute yeah and the
communists would do the closed fist red
salute today
you can walk down the street and do the
communist salute the red salute and
nobody bats an eye right don't go around
doing the nazis so that people will beat
you up right so uh with with europe you
had people who want to erase culture
like in china for instance the culture
revolution they wanted to purge the old
the fascists wanted to return to
tradition
these people
want to purge tradition
they want to purge religion they want to
purge tradition they want to create a
new system they are amoral
authoritarians so it is more in the
communist vein yeah oh it's definitely
communist
um
but communism and so so i think
communism is the is the mechanism with
which
fascism is is empowered because i define
fascism as being the control of the
economy right and and communism is like
the process of centralizing everything
you know even when you look at the ten
planks of marxism i always talk about
this the word centralization pops up in
there twice right centralization of
credit within the hands of state and
centralization of communication right
and and we're starting to see in the
united states there is fcc obviously
exists but there is a centralization of
communication the press because it's all
the same people right
so you see that you know popping up
united states but i see communism is i
see the united states as being a
communist utopia already like if if marx
was alive today he'd be like damn y'all
are good
he'd really love it
because people don't know that they're
living in the communist people think
they're living in a capitalistic
it's like no the capitalism is
supporting the communism and it's and
and and and if that right you look at
what china's doing
i love the political compass that
someone took it and then folded the left
and the right together and put china
because they're communists but they use
market forces and systems yes as a means
of control yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there